ta monsieur sylvain bergos pour le
groupe l'est républicain ce président ce
premier ministre depuis le début du
quinquennat de françois hollande
les communes semble être votre principal
vos principaux bouc émissaire récurrent
sur les emprunts toxiques vous avez pris
le parti de protéger les banques contre
les communes et les villes attendent
toujours les arbitrages définitifs
concernant le fonds de soutien sur les
baisses des dotations vous donner des
leçons vous prétendez en tout cas
pouvoir en donner
alors que toutes les collectivités
doivent voter un budget en équilibre et
que l'emprunt doit financer
exclusivement l'investissement cette
double contrainte l'état sans la
franchit allègrement en augmentant de
surcroît les impôts sur la métropole du
grand paris les maires ont travaillé
dans le cadre de la mission de
préfiguration pour définir ensemble des
périmètres correspondant à des projets
de territoire dynamique périmètre que
vous êtes empressé de piétiner par
décret pire vous avez accepté de
recevoir des maires de votre famille
politique pour en négocier les contours
à matignon mais vous n'avez toujours pas
donné suite à la demande de rendez vous
de 14 maires du val de marne dont
voudriez sceller le sort sont en
discussion dans ce département près des
trois quarts des communes et
représentants des conseils municipaux
qui représentent plus de huit cent mille
habitants voteront contre les périmètres
la métropole du grand paris est un sujet
fondamental mais ce premier ministre
auquel les maires peuvent souscrire à
condition d'être respectés et écoutés
monsieur le premier ministre kan
recevrez vous les maires concernés
qu'elle suit le donnerez-vous à l'avis
unanime exprimé par les conseils
municipaux
quand écouterez vous la voie des mers et
donc la voix des français
merci monsieur bériault à la parole et à
madame marylise lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
la métropole du grand paris a été
effectivement voté en deux fois décidée
en deux fois une première fois dans la
loi map tam avec un article fortement
débattu au sénat l'assemblée une seconde
fois parce que le premier ministre a
accepté
les premiers ministres ont accepté que
l'on revoie totalement la copie de la
métropole du grand paris nous avons à la
demande de manuel valls trouver un
accord ici même pour avancer
progressivement sur ce dossier compliqué
avec deux engagements qui ont été
respectées la mission de préfiguration
qui permet aux syndicats la métropole le
grand paris sous l'autorité de monsieur
devedjian de faire un certain nombre de
propositions et de commencer à
travailler ce qu'il faut d'arrache-pied
sur le pacte financier et fiscal
mais il y avait effectivement un second
point qui est l organisation des
communes à la fois sur le territoire un
frein métropolitain et sur la nouvelle
première couronne de la métropole c'est
vrai que c'est difficile pourquoi parce
qu'en 2010 il n'y avait pas eu de
l'intercommunalité ni obligatoire ni
encouragé pratiquement sur l'ensemble de
l'île de france et donc il y avait un
vrai retard sur l'île de france que nous
avons essayé de combler moi je suis à la
disposition des élus du val de marne
pour les rencontrer parce que je les ai
j'aime rencontrer l'ensemble des élus
qui l'ont demandé on a travaillé avec
les préfets je crois en bonne
intelligence et en essayant absolument
de trouver de bonnes solutions
ce n'est pas un dossier partisans c'est
vraiment un dossier trans partisan c'est
un dossier difficile parce que nous
avons en même temps proposé et ça a été
accepté que de grands centres de
développement dans le val de marne comme
ailleurs reste en dehors de la métropole
pour équilibrer le territoire donc je
vous donne rendez vous
évidemment monsieur que vous le voulez
avec les maires du val de marne
merci madame la ministre la séance des
questions au gouvernement est terminée
nous nous engageons monsieur minery
parlement et moi à réparer le
chronomètre donc la séance est suspendue